bonsoir emmanuel vire merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors
vous avez été reçu par roselyne bachelot
ce matin avez vous le sentiment d'avoir
été entendu pas du tout et quand
j'entends le président encore moins ce
soir mais je voudrais juste réagir sur
la séquence
notre confrère aurait me busy n'annonce
les manifestations de demain par demain
c'est plus de 100 manifestations et
rassemblements qui ont lieu dans toutes
les villes de france contre la loi
sécurité globale mais le symbole est
quand même très très fort rémy visible
c'est le journaliste qui à chaque
manifestation toutes les semaines et
empêcher de travailler par les forces de
l'ordre
et même quand il ne travaille pas il est
entravée et là que le président dise
fait attention à la la pas de violence
mais mais c'est c'est irréaliste les
propos du président sont ni ravie je les
ai découverts avec vous là parce que
j'avais pas pu voir toute la séquence
est alors encore plus après avoir été
reçus ce matin par la ministre de la
culture qui était je rappelle une simple
reprise de contact puisque la
coordination nationale et les syndicats
de journalistes avaient refusé d'être
reçus la semaine dernière par monsieur
castex premier ministre puisque le
préfet l'allemand de la préfecture de
police de paris avait interdit notre
manifestation la grande marche des
libertés qui a remporté a rencontré un
succès considérable la semaine dernière
et que nous avions dû obtenir en justice
au tribunal administratif de paris qui
avait suspendu l'arrêté d'interdiction
de la manif du préfet l'allemand alors
il y aura bien une manifestation demain
vous dénoncez d'ailleurs je cite la haye
la cacophonie qui règne au sein du
gouvernement et de la majorité
parlementaire après l'annonce surtout la
réécriture intégrale de l'article 24 un
commentaire le tout à fait y'a rien de
neuf il est ce matin l'entretien avec
madame bachelot et dans les propos du
président en fait tout le monde le sait
maintenant de toute façon l'avenir de la
proposition de l'or est au sénat elle a
été adoptée à l'assemblée nationale donc
maintenant nous en tant que coordination
nationale contre cette proposition de
loi
évidemment nous nous adressons déjà aux
sénateurs mais ce matin il n'y avait
rien nouveau chez madame bachelot même
la commission proposée par le
gouvernement pour au début réécrire
l'article
on a vu que comme c'est
anticonstitutionnel c'est plus pour
réécrire l'article mais une commission
je sais pas pour discuter pour voir ce
qui va pas
le président qui était présent pressenti
pour présider cette commission le
président de la cncdh
on a appris ce matin qu'en fait il ne
pouvait même pas présider cette
commission car il faudrait qu'il
démissionne de son mandat de président
du lait du cncdh donc qu'on aurait une
commission sans président pour l'instant
il n'y a pas de lettre de mission il n'y
a pas de composition de cette commission
non on est dans le plu en amateurisme le
plus total
on comprend mal d'ailleurs parce que
même l'onu on l'a vu aujourd'hui
critique cet article 24
on comprend pourquoi le gouvernement ne
veut pas lâcher du lest sur cette
question est ce que c'est une question
de crédibilité notamment pour gérald
darmanin qui est qui a poussé cet
article 24 mois je veux pas rentrer dans
ce débat là où est ce que c'est une
stratégie du politique du président pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22 ce
que je sais pas c'est que moi j'ai
vraiment mal au coeur j'ai mal à mon
pays de voir des experts de l'onu de
voir la défenseure des droits devoirs
tous à mettre m tellement à mal l'image
de la france quoi et je vois le
président à brut comme ça balayés sadin
cela d'un revers de main mais ces essais
c'est vraiment mais ils comprennent
toujours pas et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
vraiment demain il y ait beaucoup de
gens beaucoup de citoyens dans
l'ensemble des rassemblements organisés
partout en france
donc tant que cet article 24 et les
articles 21 et 22 ans a également ne
sont pas retirés vous continuerez de
manifester bien sûr et aussi la
réécriture du schéma national de
maintien d'ordre parce que là vous avez
compris de par les annonces du président
que là dessus a rien de nouveau
en fait on nous créer un numéro vert on
va faire quoi on va signer à l'ailé on
va signer à laisser les violences
policières
mais de toute façon les violences
policières ne sont pas traitées
quant à la réforme de l'igpn elle est
toujours à l'ordre du jour le président
nous dit juste au bas y aura plus de
transparence dans le suivi des dossiers
mais les dossiers c'est par exemple 200
plaintes de journalistes qui n'ont pas
été traités par l'igpn
ou alors dont on n'a aucune nouvelle un
certain journaliste parle d'un droit à
la censure sur des reportages et des
documentaires
est-ce que vous pouvez nous nous
préciser ses propos oui tout à fait
c'est juste juste ministère de
l'intérieur qui demande à voir des
images
de production avant qu'elles puissent
être diffusées c'est complètement
hallucinant et on aime ça c'est le cas
sur certains portages lesquels pas sûr
je n'ai je n'ai pas de reportage en mai
on demande à signer des deux à ce que la
préfecture puissent voir les reportages
avant qu'il soit diffusé
ou alors la semaine dernière pendant la
manifestation plusieurs journalistes ont
reçu des messages de la sûreté nationale
qui puisse me voir les vidéos tournées
par ses journalistes afin de mettre la
lumière sur les violences qui ont lieu
pendant les manifestations
oui effectivement la lèze en curité a
demandé aussi ces images à notre chaîne
près de 90 policiers blessés la semaine
dernière qu est ce que ça vous inspire
est ce que le service gmail chine qui
est un service d'ordre aussi qui est en
place demain de votre côté vous allez
tenter de contrôler peut-être un peu
mieux cette situation amène où on est
tous temps et d'ailleurs il faudra
interroger des services de la préfecture
mais demain ce sera la quatrième
mobilisation nationale de la
coordination la préfecture reconnaît que
nous nous mettons tout en place pour que
la sécurité soit respectée demain il y
aura plus de 100 personnes sur le
service d'ordre de la manifestation
parisienne par exemple
donc ça et nous ce n'est pas à nous de
gérer le maintien de l'ordre
le maintien de nuno manifestants il n'y
a pas de souci c'est la stratégie du
maintien de l'ordre qui doit être
discuté et il suffit de voir avec les
autres pays européens en belgique en
italie au royaume uni en allemagne ce
n'est pas la même stratégie de maintien
de l'ordre
et donc il faut que vraiment il ya une
réflexion et le président l'acceptent
toujours pas ce soir il est toujours
droit dans ses bottes et nous dit oh là
là la tension mais tout ça et
caricatures au vous en faites trop mais
non non l'image de la france est
profondément dégradé tout le monde le
dit maintenant il faut retirer cette
proposition de loi et revoir
intégralement le nouveau schéma de
maintien d une réaction très court s'il
vous plaît sur l'audition de gérald
darmanin cette semaine devant
l'assemblée nationale
al il est resté droit dans ses bottes
pour un ministre de l'intérieur vous en
avez pensé quoi
6 beaucoup de haut pour tout vous dire
j'étais j'étais même peiné parce que je
moi j'ai les réactions des syndicats
européens de journalistes moi j'ai les
réactions des confrères qui ne
comprennent pas la situation du maintien
de l'ordre en france donc c'est je sais
pas comment un comment il faut faire
pour leur expliquer qu'on a besoin de
dialogue
on a besoin de comprendre oui la société
violente dans son ensemble dans tous les
pays européens
tout cela est géré il y à du dialogue on
essaie de comprendre comment les
policiers travaillent on essaie de
comprendre comment les journalistes
travaillent le problème et ça c'est la
seule chose
la seule chose que madame bachelot
ministre de la culture a reconnu en nous
recevant ce matin c'est que comme elle
l'a dit le lien de confiance est rompu
le lien de confiance est rompue à la
fois entre les journalistes et les
pouvoirs publics et les forces de l'anp
mais aussi malheureusement beaucoup
entre les citoyens et les forces de
l'ordre
et c'est ce lien qu'il faut rétablir oui
c'est ce qu'a dit le chef de l'état
également merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
d'avoir et plus il a qu'une chose à
faire si vous savez c'est retirer la
proposition de loi sécurité globale
hélas le l'apaisement sera généralisé
message entendu merci emmanuel et vire
d'avoir répondu ce soir à nos questions
sur rt france